many times we have this idea that we
just need to increase more protein to
build our muscles because after all
muscles are made out of protein right
but then when a lot of people do this it
doesn't always work so in fact there's
actually a paradox involved here some
people that eat more protein might even
suffer from an individual amino acid
deficiency so whether you're trying to
prevent muscle loss as you're getting
older that's called sarcopenia or
whether you're trying to increase more
muscle I want to talk about some other
factors that are not related directly to
protein consumption even though you do
need sufficient protein consumption to
build muscles but more than that you
need sufficient amount of amino acids
now when you look up the minimum amount
of protein you need
there's a lot of inflicting information
out there but the general consensus is
you need a 0.8 grams per kilogram of
lean body weight
not your overall weight so let's say for
example you weigh like 400 pounds and
you have a lot of extra fat it doesn't
mean you should start massively
increasing your protein you should
calculate that based on your lean body
mass so 0.8 grams per kilogram of lean
body mass is kind of like on the low end
that's like the minimum amount and that
on average could be around 50 grams of
protein per day now when I say protein
I'm talking about the protein in your
food for example if you take a steak and
you have like a hundred grams of steak
right the weight of it that only has
roughly about 26 grams of protein in
that 100 gram
steak so it's the protein in the food
not the actual weight of the food now a
moderate amount of protein could be
between like 1.2 and 1.7 grams per
kilogram of lean body weight and then
when we get into higher protein that
that's roughly about like two grams uh
per kilogram of lean body weight and a
lot of weight lifters will do that
amount and even a lot more too so but
I'm not going to get into whether you
should do that or not do that I'm just
kind of giving you some ideas on the
ranges of how much protein you should
have but I want to really focus on these
other factors that influence the
production of muscle protein itself now
in a couple points I want to even touch
on is your body doesn't normally store a
lot of protein as like a reserve okay so
it doesn't store that so if you eat too
much protein it'll just convert the
excess into glucose bodybuilders
sometimes like that because sometimes
they want to increase insulin effects
okay from glucose because insulin is
anabolic and they want to build their
muscle mass and if they're fortunate
enough not to have insulin resistance
and maybe they're immune to it whatever
versus the rest of us that have insulin
resistance that may work for them but
for the majority of the population when
they start increasing
more sugar glucose or even glucose from
protein and thereby increasing more
insulin the body tends to now create
insulin resistance so it's kind of a
catch-22 here you're trying to increase
more insulin
but the more you try to do it the more
you're creating insulin resistance to
the point where now you have a
deficiency of insulin okay that's what
insulin resistance is
so how does that affect your muscles
well guess what you need insulin to
absorb amino acids so the more insulin
resistance you have
the less ability you're going to be able
to use these proteins for your own
muscles so that's barrier number one
insulin resistance how is that created
by eating too many carbs and it could be
also created by consuming too much
protein too so on the flip side if we
want to correct insulin resistance we
want to get in a low carb diet we want
to not eat as frequently
and this is the other point I want to
bring up about protein so many people
have this idea that they have to be
constantly eating protein when they're
working out before or after or even
during having these protein powders and
these shakes in these bars but in fact
that's going to actually rebound on the
person many times because it's going to
act as a snack it's going to increase
insulin but create more insulin
resistance and it's really not needed
for many reasons but definitely insulin
resistance is one reason the other
factor involved with building muscles is
growth hormone
um and there are some things that you
want to know about growth hormone how do
you first trigger growth hormone well
you can trigger it by intense exercise
so if you're trying to build muscle with
just eating protein and not exercising
it's not going to work exercise is the
most potent activator of muscle
synthesis especially intense exercise as
well as the volume of exercise too so
it's not just doing a short little
intense workout it's really increasing
the volume and the load on the muscles
doing like resistance type exercise but
exercise will stimulate growth hormone
okay and it also stimulates testosterone
too
both necessary for building muscle now
another thing that you can do to
increase growth hormone is fasting right
fasting and not snacking so frequently
so fasting can increase growth hormone
and if you're trying to build muscle I
would just do intermittent fasting okay
get them in a fasting not eat so
frequently eat two meals a day I think
that would be a lot better than three
meals a day now with intermittent
fasting your hunger will go down so you
just want to make sure that you have
enough calories too because especially
if you have a fast metabolism growth
hormone also can be inhibited by
high blood glucose levels that's why I
like the low carb I like intermittent
fasting and a good exercise plan as well
as a good amount of recovery from sleep
all of those factors can help increase
growth hormone now as far as
testosterone goes there's several things
you need to be aware of the zinc
deficiency can create a low testosterone
so zinc can definitely increase your
testosterone now where do you get zinc
from red meat shellfish Seafood
way more than plant type foods how do
you create a zinc deficiency by eating
too many refined carbs too much sugar
going through stress the other thing
that can inhibit testosterone is having
too much estrogen okay now where does
that come from well mainly comes from
like a lot of the soy protein isolate
Foods soy milk can do it you also
increase estrogen when you drink beer
okay yeah and also assume alcohol
now another way to create a problem with
amino acids is to consume foods low in
certain amino acids like plant-based
proteins whether you're a vegetarian or
a vegan or consuming a lot of
plant-based protein which are considered
clean proteins many times are low in
certain amino acids and one amino acid
that I want to bring up is leucine
leucine is a potent stimulus of the
production of muscle so mostly going to
see low leucine Foods in plant-based
foods but you're not going to see this
in animal Meats things like that so it's
the type of protein that's important too
eggs meat fish Dairy all very very
important now another factor is stress
stress produces cortisol cortisol is
very catabolic that's the opposite of
antibiotic so it tends to break things
down if you're under chronic stress that
can wear your muscles down Big Time
primarily it starts out in the thigh
muscle the quadricep and then it goes
after the glutamus Maximus and it can
convert some of that that protein into
sugar which then is converted to fat
around your midsection okay
so that's just another factor to be
aware of another factor is the
microbiome microbiome is indefinitely
involved in helping you make amino acids
and other factors in helping you make
protein in general and so if someone had
a lot of antibiotics many times they
start having all sorts of problems with
their muscles building muscles and
maintaining uh muscles so consuming more
Probiotic foods like fermented foods
like sauerkraut things like that that
are very very good now the other thing
that I I've run into with people is that
they just don't have enough stomach acid
to break down the protein to then turn
into muscle so they never have this uh
fully broke down protein product into
the amino acids so hydrochloric acid is
very very important especially as we age
the stomach acid goes down so you need
to start to support that so you get the
full breakdown of amino acids so butane
hydrochloride is a really good thing to
start taking with your meals to enhance
the amino acids into the muscle
how do you know if you have a problem or
deficiency of hydrochloric acid well one
way is indigestion or acid reflux or
gerd if you have that you should watch
the link down below now also enzymes
enzymes mainly from the pancreas and
even from the small intestine can be a
factor if you don't have enough enzymes
you're not going to be able to break
down certain foods that then can turn
into these pure amino acids so a couple
things with the pancreas you could have
a like bile sludge that can build up
that can create pancreatitis
so that's the problem with the bile and
the way that you probably have that is
you get a lot of bloating or you have
referred pain to your left or right
shoulder
I put a link down below if you have that
or you have some type of malabsorption
in your small intestine or your large
intestine where there's inflammation or
past gut problems that have been really
hindering your ability to absorb protein
in which case you might need to take an
amino acid supplement and then the other
factor I want to bring up is when you
eat protein right you have to realize
that the ideal protein for your body to
absorb
um would be in its natural form with fat
versus lean protein okay the leaner a
protein is the harder it is to digest
and the more problems it can create
there's some interesting data on that in
relationship to people eating just you
know very very lean protein and no fat
and what that does to your bodies
there's a there's a lot of problems with
that so I recommend always consume the
fat that normally comes with that
protein if possible or if you're eating
chicken have the skin on it or fish try
to have the skin on it that's much
better and this also includes like so
many people are doing this refined
protein by having protein powders all
the time I mean a little bit of that is
okay but if you're just relying
exclusively on protein powders it's not
the ideal scene to build healthy muscles
especially since they put all this
maltodection and this corn syrup in
there and all sorts of crap but in this
video I just wanted to go beyond the SE
dietary protein and give you some other
factors especially if you're trying to
build muscle or prevent the loss of
muscle as you age now since I brought up
growth hormone it's a really important
topic and if you haven't seen my video
on growth hormone you should probably
check that out I put it up right here